[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen das
Wichtigste vom Sport an diesem Sonntag
hat Norbert Lehmann für Sie einen
schönen guten Abend die Themen im
Überblick
ist der Streit um die Kinder
Grundsicherung bald vorbei im ZDF
sommerinterview sagt FDP-Chef Lindner
die Ampel könnte sich sehr rasch auf
Eckpunkte verständigen
schockierendes Hassverbrechen in den USA
erschießt ein junger weißer gezielt drei
schwarze aus rassistischen Motiven wie
die Polizei sagt und getrieben von einer
ekelhaften Ideologie
und leider kein Bronze bei der Hockey EM
im eigenen Land verliert das deutsche
Team im kleinen Finale gegen
Olympiasieger Belgien und wird Vierter
[Musik]
heute Spitzengespräch im Kanzleramt zur
Kindergrundsicherung die große Frage ist
weiterhin wie viel die
Kindergrundsicherung kosten soll die
grüne Familie Ministerin Paulus will
deutlich mehr dafür ausgeben als FDP
Finanzminister Lindner vom Treffen mit
Kanzler Scholz weil Linden am ZDF
sommerinterview mehr dazu von Christian
hübscher
sonntags im Kanzleramt Kanzler und
Finanzminister verhandeln mit
Familienministerin Paus es ist schon das
vierte Krisentreffen in einer Woche
wieder zur Kindergrundsicherung am
Nachmittag im zdf-sommer Interview macht
Christian Lindner erst Hoffnung es
könnte bald ausgestanden sein um dann
gleich wieder zu bremsen ich rechne
damit dass wir sehr kurzfristig eine
Einigung über die Eckpunkte haben was
getan werden soll aber danach gibt es ja
auch sehr viel technisch was noch
geklärt werden muss dann werden Verbände
und Länder beteiligt und dann wird es
erst ein fertigen Gesetzentwurf geben
Pause will Armin Familien mit Kindern
direkt mehr Geld geben Lindner
stattdessen mehr in Frühförderung
investieren wir wecken hier den Eindruck
dass es das ist dort um Verelendung geht
das gibt es in unserem Sozialstaaten
nicht sondern wir
engagieren uns bereits sehr stark mit
vielen vielen Milliarden Euro Kritik an
der Ampel Hängepartie kommt aus einem
anderen sommerinterview
Opposition Chef März vermisst ein
Konzept ich würde ganz gerne mal wissen
was ist diese Kindergrundsicherung von
Frau Paus eigentlich wir werden mit
diesem Thema seit Monaten konfrontiert
da Geistern Zahlen durch die Landschaft
12 Milliarden 8 Milliarden 7 dann
reichen plötzlich zwei dieses Flackern
der Ampel es tut Lindners FDP jedenfalls
nicht gut Dauerstreit mit den Grünen
Absturz in den Umfragen fünf verlorene
Landtagswahlen seitdem läuft das Projekt
Profil schärfen bei den Liberalen mit
bisher mäßigem Erfolg die Koalition ist
schwierig das kann niemanden überraschen
die drei Parteien haben völlig
unterschiedliche Programme da gibt es
einmal ein Auf und Ab in Umfragen und es
gibt auch einmal wahlabende nach einer
Landtagswahl die wünscht man sich anders
aber in der jetzigen Situation
entscheidend ist was anderes wir müssen
die Inflation bekämpfen und deshalb muss
die Schuldenbremse geachtet werden sie
wird jeden Tag hart umstritten jeden Tag
Kontroverse der öffentliche Eindruck der
Koalition sei nicht zufriedenstellen zu
Lindner an einen raus aus der Ampel aber
denke er nicht
der Kanzler hatte angekündigt dass der
Streit um die Kindergrundsicherung bis
Anfang der Woche beigelegt sein werde
statt energy ist da heute schon mit
einer Einigung zu rechnen die Ampel
steht zumindest unter sehr großem Druck
zu beweisen dass sie sich auch bei
schwierigen Fragen schnell einigen kann
und das Wort das Kanzlers wird sicher
nicht alle kalt lassen aber wenn man im
Finanzminister zugehört hat dann hat man
eben auch gehört dass es vielleicht nur
eine grundsätzliche Einigung geben kann
heute und in den nächsten Tagen und das
immer noch viele technische Fragen zu
klären sind und interessant in dem
Zusammenhang ist auch dass die
FDP-Bundestagsabgeordnete die die ganzen
gestern schon gesagt hat also bis zur
Kabinettsklausur in mieseberg kann gar
nicht alles ausgehandelt und fertig
durchdacht sein da bräuchte man viel
länger um alles zu prüfen dass er
erinnert ein wenig daran wie das beim
heizungsgesetz gelaufen ist als das
Kabinett das die Gesetzesvorlage nicht
ganz geeinigt in den Bundestag
weitergereicht hat und sich die
ampelparteien danach öffentlich darüber
zerlegt haben das soll jetzt natürlich
aus Ampel sich nicht noch einmal
passieren und deswegen wird es
sicherlich Bemühungen geben das Ganze
bis zur kabinettsklasse werden Meseberg
zumindest so weit zu bringen wie es geht
vielen Dank für diese Einordnung in
Berlin
und das ganze sommerinterview mit dem
FDP-Chef sehen Sie direkt im Anschluss
die SPD will Mieterhöhungen stärker
begrenzen in einem beschlusspapier für
die spd-fraktionsklausur morgen ist von
einem bundesweiten mietenstopp die Rede
konkret wird darin allerdings lediglich
gefordert das Mieten entgegende mit
angespannten Wohnungsmarkt innerhalb von
drei Jahren um höchstens sechs Prozent
steigen dürfen derzeit sind es 15%
. und wir schauen nach Bayern und zu den
Vorwürfen gegen den stellvertretenden
Ministerpräsidenten Aiwanger er habe in
seiner Jugend ein antisemitisches
Flugblatt verfasst gestern Abend meldete
sich der ältere Bruder aiwangers und
teilte mit dass er das Flugblatt
geschrieben habe
Aiwanger der Spitzenkandidat für die
Freien Wähler bei der Landtagswahl ist
nahm heute wieder Termine war zu den
Vorwürfen äußerte er sich dabei nicht
vier Tage nach dem Flugzeugabsturz in
der Nähe von Moskau haben russische
Behörden jetzt bestätigt der Chef der
Söldnergruppe Wagner
das habe eine DNA-Analyse ergeben die
Ursache des Unglücks ist weiter unklar
das Flugzeug war am Mittwoch kurz nach
dem Start vom Himmel gestürzt war nach
einer Meuterei im Juni in Russland in
Ungnade gefallen
in den USA ist ein rassistischer Angriff
verübt worden der weiße Attentäter
erschoss drei schwarze Menschen in einem
Geschäft in Jacksonville Florida danach
erschoss er sich selbst in einem
Manifest habe sich der teetarassistisch
geäußert teilte die Polizei mit das FBI
leitete eine Untersuchung wegen eines
hassverbrechens ein ein Bericht von
Benjamin Daniel
schon wieder Unschuldige erschossen
schon wieder gezielte Morde an schwarzen
ein Supermarkt wird zum Tatort der
Schütze ein Mann Anfang 20 er tötet drei
Menschen und dann sich selbst
es gibt keine Belege dafür dass der
Schützer einer größeren Gruppe angehörte
er handelte allein wenn Sie sich die
Bilder anschauen werden Sie sehen welche
Waffen er benutzt hat eine Glock und ein
AR-15 Sturmgewehr
immer wieder versucht die US-Regierung
das Waffenrecht zu verschärfen
insbesondere den Zugang zu Sturmgewehren
wollen die Demokraten einschränken doch
die mächtige Waffenlobby und die
Republikaner lassen das nicht zu einer
ihrer prominentesten Vertreter äußerte
sich zum Vorfall
den Grund für die Schießerei hat der
Drecksack in eine manifesta gelegt seine
Tat war rassistisch motiviert das ist
absolut inakzeptabel
und doch sind weniger aus seiner Partei
bereit es hasstätern schwerer zu machen
an Sturmgewehre zu gelangen und damit
unschuldige aus dem Leben zu reißen
das macht mich fertig es ist nicht fair
dass wir nicht mal sicher sind wenn wir
auf dem Bürgersteig laufen oder
einkaufen gehen
und so bleibt die wieder einmal eine
schwarze Gemeinde in den USA erschüttert
zurück in Trauer und Angst weil ein
weißer Rassist viel zu leicht an Waffen
gelangen konnte
blicken wir jetzt auf die Ferieninsel
Mallorca dort dürfte heute den meisten
Touristinnen und Touristen angesichts
des Wetters die Urlaubsstimmung
vergangen sein seit dem Vormittag [__]
heftige Unwetter über die Insel mit
Hagel starkem Regen und Windböen mit
Geschwindigkeiten bis zu 100 km pro
Stunde die Behörden hat man alle
appelliert ihre Häuser und Hotels nicht
zu verlassen
besonders getroffen hat es die
Inselhauptstadt Palma
und nur ein letztes Mal zur hockeya in
Mönchengladbach Norbert da haben die
deutschen Männer ja die Bronzemedaille
verpasst ja im Spiel um Platz drei eine
Null zu zwei Niederlage gegen vor allem
defensivstarke Belgier unterm Strich ein
eher enttäuschender Auftritt der
Weltmeister aus Deutschland bei dieser
Heime
zum Ende eines ausgeglichenen ersten
Viertels trifft Nelson onana zum 1:0 für
die Belgier unhaltbar für Alexander
Stadler im deutschen Tor in der 28
Minute schafft es von Obel den Ball im
Fall mit der Rückhand zu treffen das
verdiente 2:0 wir sind hier gegen alle
anderen Nation die ungefähr auf unserem
Level sind haben wir verloren im äh wenn
es noch ankam das müssen wir besser
machen um das nächste Ziel erreichen zu
können eine olympische Medaille 2024 in
Paris
okay Europameister wurden die
Niederländer im Finale gegen den Titel
Verteidiger England gewann sie mit 2:1
die deutschen Basketballer haben auch
ihr zweites wir im Gruppenspiel gewonnen
das bis zur letzten Sekunde spannende
Duell gegen Australien endete mit 85:82
Alexandra Popp ist zum dritten Mal
fußball-rennen des Jahres die
Wolfsburgerin war letzte Saison
Torschützenkönigin der Bundesliga ja
deutsches Doppelgold zum Abschluss der
Kanu WM in Duisburg Tim Hacker und Peter
Kretschmer siegten im Kanadier zweier
und qualifizierten sich damit für die
Olympischen Spiele und ebenfalls Gold
gab es für Lena röhlings und Jakob Shop
im gemischten Kajak über 500 m
heute auch der Abschluss der
Leichtathletik WM in Budapest noch keine
deutsche Medaille Hoffnungsträger Leo
Neugebauer der wurde gestern Abend im
Zehnkampf fünfter gleich aber könnte
Speerwerfer Julian Weber für die erste
und wohl einzige dlhorn Medaille sorgen
live zu sehen bei uns im ZDF ab
20:15 Uhr ja und das fünfte Deutsche WM
Gold dagegen das hat da ja Fall von
Familie in der rhythmischen sportmin das
Gymnastik geholt das 16-jährige
Ausnahmetalent hatte zuvor bereits alle
vier Einzeltitel gewonnen und siegte
gestern Abend auch im meerkampf das
hatte vor ihr noch keine deutsche
Gymnastik geschafft und Publikum
gefeiert wie ein Popstar absolut
so aktuell warnt der Deutsche
Wetterdienst vor ergiebigen Dauerregen
am Alpenrand und so sind die Aussichten
morgen regnet es im Süden und Südosten
anhaltend und ergiebig große Regenmengen
sind am Alpenrand zu erwarten einige
wenige Schauer ziehen ganz im Norden
durch dazwischen zeigt sich oft die
Sonne
Höchsttemperaturen von 11 bis 22 Grad
das heute journal läuft um 22 Uhr mit
Maria das lomka Morgen begrüßt Sie hier
mit riserin und jetzt geht's weiter mit
dem ZDF sommerinterview mit dem
Finanzminister auf Wiedersehen